have you ever played a game for five
hours straight
ten how about 60 hours well that's how
long brazilian streamer nick link played
league of legends for last week as he
went from unranked to masters in a
single sitting he didn't sleep during
those two and a half days and only left
his computer to eat or use the bathroom
the jacks main played an astounding 90
solo queue games in a row and finished
his run with a 78 win rate
now this isn't the first time that nick
link has tried this insane challenge but
previous attempts saw him give up around
the 30-hour mark this time though he
powered through to celebrate his
birthday on the day the stream ended of
course playing that many games in a row
would take its toll on anyone and i can
only hope that nickling had a long lie
down after it maybe a cup of tea